jen was a dream to work with she's an
absolute pro
and totally engaged and loved the
project i've known her forever so it was
it was easy for us to sort of get in
lock step
one of those situations that everything
kind of fit perfectly
talk to me a little bit about jumping
into the suit for the first time
as this superhuman how was that did your
son axel
approve of the project well it was
something that
was definitely a project that i didn't
see coming
it wasn't something that i expected to
do at this point in my career
uh but i read the script and it was kind
of the perfect fit i was old enough to
play the older version i was young
enough for the younger version
and what an opportunity as an actor to
be able to you know play the same guy
but
you know 90 years apart and that's
that's really what it is really two
different people and
and so getting into that superhero suit
for the first time was
uh empowering to say the least that
muscle suit man that's no joke
90 years 90 years and what do we have to
show for him
we've made a different show
what was the physical training like for
this type of stuff
and what was the makeup chair process
like
well there was a lot of training that
went involved i think everybody on the
cast had a pretty strict regimen that
they had us on and it was
it was great because how often do you
have to go to the gym normally you have
to go do it of your own volition but
here we had to do it so i wish i had
that same
sort of regimen all the time i'd be in
excellent shape but
you know um as far as as far as
the the process of getting into that
that
that that get up every day was it was a
lot i think we got it down to about an
hour and a half
you know you have the prosthetics and
you got the aging makeup and the beard
and the wig and then the suit
and it's always interesting to like walk
out of the set in the morning before you
have all the stuff on to do rehearsal or
whatever
and nobody really gives two looks but
then you walk in
as the utopian imposing figure so
uh you know it was fun until i had to
take it off and i
got back to my own sort of uh skinny
gangly self listen do you feel at all
like you got like a glimpse into the
future with the aging process
i hope i look like that when i'm 120
years old
uh but yeah it was it was that it was
that long
gray you know moses slash
i don't know santa claus look that that
i loved you know it was like it was
somewhere it was it was like this
this this old hippie in a weird way it's
like he kind of given up
you know trying to keep up his his clean
cut superhero look and and just sort of
went for the
grateful dead look i can tell you this
josh
i work in a office full of powerful
badass women and they all love you with
long gray hair i'm just going to tell
you oh they do
well there you go maybe i could grow it
i mean i've tried growing my hair like
that before and it never
never turns out like that i'll tell you
that it'd be perfect
if you're joining a band for sure yeah
like it's like it's like you know
the allman brothers or something totally
in a super suit
yeah yeah yeah now listen you're a
fierce father right in the
in the series you buy the books by the
rules how does your
personal parenting style compare to the
show are you are you strict at home
are you channeling your your real life
paternal side on this show or is it two
different things well i think that this
show is for me a cautionary tale in a
lot of ways because
myself and sheldon sampson the utopian
are very similar and that we're both
very ambitious we both
you know aren't afraid to take on a lot
but i think where he made his mistake
was that he
became so caught up in being this guy
and
you know saving the world that he forgot
to to be there for his children as much
as he should have and i think that
for me
you know if you don't if you don't
connect with your kids if you don't have
that relationship
at the end of the day what is it all
worth what is it all for
and and that's really what i want to be
cautious of
is making sure that he knows that he is
number one and that he's
he's my priority and that we always have
a great relationship because
my dad and i have a great relationship
and i'm so grateful for that
and and and i think you know hopefully i
can do the same
yeah and how and how beautifully
self-aware you are
to mirror and feel and
share those lessons between your real
life and your character that's that's
pretty awesome thing that you're taking
away
um from a show you know speaking of
speaking of this show and the
physicality of it talk a little bit
about the training um
you know what what did you have to do
physically to kind of prepare for this
well there was a lot of a lot of
training that went into it
like i said we had every day
we were we were scheduled to go in for
two hours
and we trained really hard you know all
of us tried to get into the best shape
we could
um but you know mentally for me was was
more of the the fun part was getting in
shape i love
i love doing that especially when i'm
sort of told to go do it
it's the mental prep that it took to get
into this this guy's head space you know
in the origin story he's in his 30s
right
after the crash of 29 and witnesses
you know his father tragically die
in front of him and it throws him into
this psychological tailspin
and i had to go to some pretty dark
places yeah and
that takes a toll on you mentally after
three or four weeks of doing it and
and you know as exhausting as that was
it was also
uh therapeutic in a weird way because
you get to expel some stuff that
you don't even know is in you and that's
one of the beauties of getting to do
this for a living is you get to like go
to places you would never otherwise go
yeah it's uh it's funny but i i gotta
reference a book there's a book that
talks about training the tiger we all
have this darkness this tiger inside of
us and if you don't throw that leash on
it
it eventually consumes you so i i
related to what you're saying very well
yeah um you got this show coming out
this show is obviously
going to get numerous seasons it's going
to be a huge big deal you also
instagrammed out to save the date for
shotgun wedding
how awesome was it stepping in for army
and working with jennifer lopez man
it was one of the most fun experiences
i've had shooting
uh for working in this business you
first of all we're in the dominican
republic which is absolutely beautiful
yeah jen was a dream to work with she's
an absolute pro
and totally engaged and loved the
project we got off
you know we had a great relationship um
i've known her forever so it was it was
easy for us to sort of get in lock step
and you know the the crew the the cast
we got a great cast
jason moore the director was it was just
it was one of those one of those
one of those situations that everything
kind of fit perfectly and i'm very proud
of the way it turned out and i can't
wait for it to all come together
yeah i mean the picture you instagrammed
out had us all like man i can't wait to
see this there's an interesting shot
um let's i'll let you get out of here in
a second talk to me real quick about one
more instagram post are you still
auditioning for boyd band members
are you are you asking if you can send a
video because you might be perfect you
got the look man
you got the look at josh demelle and
i'll be i'll be happy to
run you through the audition process all
right when i get the guts to send that
video i promise i will send it until
then
keep keep being like you'd be like the
cute quirky shy one you know what i mean
you need one
oh stop stop
you